[موسيقى]
جبال شاهقه مهيبه في غريان الليبيه قاسيه
في مظهرها الوعر رئيفه في تل ابيبها
الدفئه تجوف صفوحها بات التحفن معماريه في
التاريخ المعاصر تعود الى عصرين من الزمن
لكن ما صمد منها لا يقل عمرها عن ثلاثه
قرون كانت بيوتا تضم الليبيين بين جدرانها
الصخريه فاسمه تلك المدينه يحكي قصتها اذ
قيل ان الجزء الاول من الكلمه يعني الكهف
امتيان فنسبه الى امبراطور رومانيه كان
يقتلها
تشق الحياه سبيلها في لب الجبال وتمضي
الايام دون ان يبلى اثاثها لتصبح مازارا
تاريخيا يستقطب السياح حول العالم الى قمه
الجبل الغربي الرابطه على علو 700 متر
عائلتي بالحج التي ابت ان تهجر هذا المكان
على الاقل ان تدعى له نصيبا من الذكريات
كواجبا يقع على عاتق افرادها كورثه لهذه
الكهوف
الوضع الامني انه لكن في تحسن طبعا الوضع
الامني جيد في مدينه الخريان طبعا
التوافق الزوار من جميع انحاء العالم من
اليابان من اوروبا من بريطانيا من امريكا
من من التايلاند ما نزلوا اطلق عليها
الليبيون بيوت الحفر او كما يسمونها
الدموس مساكن بنيت بشق الانفس وبادوات
بدائيه
وبقدر رحابتي صدر حفرها وسعه هي تلك الغرف
تهب فيها نسمه الماضي بعبق التاريخ
منشات لجؤوا اليها لياتوا بظلالها وهوائها
الذي يبقى صيف شتاء عند درجه حراره لا
تتخطى العشرين اسراء الصغير العربيه
[موسيقى]